here is you know
how are you today also I challenge you
to share something you don't usually
share with the next stranger I'm fine
having a good day I'm a radical feminist
are you I honestly don't even know those
dis business how are you helping society
wait for word
well how did help Society I'm just
trying to be a good person did you do a
good thing today alright I did I kind of
helped a friend just now earlier but uh
doing there's a financial advice
yeah so hopefully she'll do better next
month and this month itself and you're
helping me right now yeah exactly I'm
helping you right now
you know with the video so that's cool
what are you doing in your spare time I
guess like homework pretty much what I'm
not at work work and
between school play video games and
stuff my biggest fear is becoming an
irresponsible person because that's how
my father was what's your biggest fear
and why my biggest fear would probably
be failure
but just because
something that's out of my control can
you define failure to you like what you
got me my probably like letting down the
people that in my life that I've
considered like my family my friends
that I love so many times in life we
constantly strive to be good enough for
someone else know that you are good
enough always work in progress getting
better every day
yeah those really nice and I kind of
needed it you're doing fine
it's good it's good a reassurance I
guess yeah doing alright my shoulders
kind of been killing me some cracks them
in everybody yeah it's doing pretty fine
[Music]
happiness is relative
and it is a drawing of a yin-yang symbol
it's a nice platitude especially on a
you know overcast fall day I can feel
that your dreams are the only thing you
can take with you
how are you realizing them today
[Applause]
okay I mean I kind of like I don't
really really get it I mean you would
sort of take them into account for like
everything you do like in your day to
day life I guess a little bit more
I don't know my feet are sweaty how soft
are your hands and then it's signed
whoever this person is I think that it
reminds me of gin that's what I did
because gin has that kind of weird taste
at the end of me the kinds like sweaty
feet I tell people that's not mine
know when to leave the conversation of
the not knowing I'll leave it at know
when to leave the conversation before it
gets too emotional
[Music]
if bromb wearing friends would that be a
trip or what that would be a sick trip I
would do it tomorrow
thanks for watching another episode if
you haven't already it would mean a lot
if you subscribe to my channel like this
video I shared a couple episodes with
friends and help support my project
thank you
[Music]